this is Olivia an East African crowned  crane she is stunning she stands about 4  feet tall with a wingspan of six and a  half feet her legs are long and slender  perfect for wading through grassy areas  mostly grey the wings are predominantly  white with a range of colors while her  head is full of golden feathers East  African crowned cranes are well known  for their elaborate dancing these cranes  are omnivores eating everything from  plants to insects snakes small fish and  more native to eastern sub-saharan  Africa and down to South Africa they  prefer living in grassland areas near  the water the crowned crane is the  national bird of Uganda featured on its  flag but even with such iconic status  we're losing them in less than 10 years  their population has decreased by over  50% habitat loss and illegal removal of  eggs and birds from the wild are its  biggest threats this is the East African  crowned crane  you